like plot versus story like plot is like  the things that are happening and the  story is like what it's actually about  and like the plot should be the thing  that seems the most important at first  and the story should be like in there  but almost recognizable and then as the  movie goes on like that ratio should  completely reverse itself you know I  remember with four-year-old virgin  that's what Judd was saying like that  was the first real like Movie experience  I had and listen the problem most men  have is they just plain straight up have  no clue how to talk to women because I  was like this movie's really like good  and smart and emotional like why are we  calling it for your version of like and  the trailers just seem so like reductive  and he was like no the whole thing is  like we're going to trick people into  seeing a movie that is smarter than one  they would want to see and I was like oh  I get that it's actually smart